- Hi, it's me, Ross Matthews.
And guess what?
It's bring your fiance to work day,
because Dr. Wellington Garcia,
my man is here.
We debuted exclusively,
the new cover of "The Knot" magazine with,
who is that?
What's his name again?
- My husband to be.
- Yeah that one.
On the cover Wellington
and I have a spread inside
celebrating our upcoming nuptials.
Very exciting day,
and while we were here we
thought we'd play around
in the digital studio.
Are you down?
- Oh my God, so excited.
- Okay.
- Do this.
- Let's hit it.
(upbeat music)
You think?
- Okay you.
- Yeah, ah-ha, ah-ha.
He'd book the travel, but I would plan it.
(upbeat music)
I do.
- I'm a natural beauty so.
(laughing)
- Can we call this off?
The whole thing?
(upbeat music)
That would be me,
but I'm never really late.
I just always think I'm gonna be early.
- Right, you just don't know how
traffic in New York actually works.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
But I'm rarely late.
I just don't.
Yeah, it's me.
(upbeat music)
(clears throat)
Hello?
- Hello Rossipies.
- It's a Rossipies, ta-dah.
Thank you, sell it.
- That's it.
- Hashtag thank you.
(upbeat music)
Can we share this one?
- Share that.
I mean that's the beauty
of like gay relationships.
- Yeah.
- Double your wardrobe so.
- Yeah, hm-mm.
I know it really,
I can't recommend it enough.
We even wear
the same shoe size.
- Yeah.
- And we rarely spend time
in the closet anymore,
but we (laughs) now we have
a lot of clothes in there.
(upbeat music)
- That'll be me.
- That's him.
- I'm a good reservation maker.
- Yeah, we're going to dinner tonight,
and you wanna know where?
- [Producer] Yeah.
- So would I,
I don't know where 'cause.
- Surprise.
(upbeat music)
- Neither.
- No.
- We wake up.
We are like active senior citizens,
we are up at like,
well, there's a five
in front of it.
- Five.
- [Both] 5:30.
- 5:45.
- If I'm up, he's up.
(upbeat music)
Oh our tastes are so diff,
so I think I make a great playlist
but he'd be like,
I've never heard this song in my life.
And I'll be like, it's Donna Summer.
And he'll be like, who's that?
(laughing)
- You do the same.
I, you know, try to get you
some hip-hop stuff in your life.
Say that again.
- Yeah, I don't know the hip-hop so much.
(upbeat music)
- Me.
- I wanna do it.
- I want it.
- I'm excited.
(laughing)
- I love you.
- Love you.
(lips smacking)
- That's my man.
(upbeat music)